Joan we had a question come in from mr.
Monnet and he asks what should a writer
know about story in the age of binge
viewing such as some of the Netflix
series that are out right now the advent
of serials has totally changed not just
how story works in television but how
viewers react to that how yours
experience television now binge viewing
of course doesn't exist when we're
talking about say a detective show a
standalone show you wouldn't sit there
and watch ten episodes of Castle because
every one of those is essentially the
same story binge viewing happens when
you have a serial whether it's in drama
or in comedy and these Netflix these
sorts of shows are a good example of
that I remember last summer they AMC put
on Breaking Bad from the very beginning
to their most recent episode
now when Breaking Bad first came out I
wasn't interested in watching and I
thought all this is another show about a
guy who who sells drugs you know who
needs to see this it's gonna be the same
old thing well when they put it on in
one a day which essentially allowed me
to binge you for you know for a month
and a half on Breaking Bad the
experience of that show was totally
different because what I was able to see
is not only why this is one of the
greatest TV shows that has ever been
done but I got to see why it's one of
the greatest shows ever done and it had
to do with the ability of that writing
staff to not only write great individual
episodes but to sequence the episodes of
the course of the season and ultimately
over the course of the entire show and
it was almost like wine tasting and I
think that's what what binge viewing is
like
because when you're wine-tasting you
immediately get to compare these
different wines and it becomes very
clear why this wine is better than that
wine when you do binge viewing you get
to the links between the episodes become
much clearer and you see the true
artistry of these storytellers in their
ability to build a series of episodes to
the climactic final episode of that
season and then to withhold certain
things that have to be withheld to set
up the opening episode of the next
season and so this this whole use of the
serial writing is causing people to have
an entirely different experience of how
they watch television and how they
appreciate television because they think
this is also one of the places where
people are realizing that the best story
work in American entertainment business
is in television right now and and by
the way do classes all over the world
the single biggest interest wherever I
go is to talk about and understand
American television because they
understand that the quality of American
television is the highest it has ever
been it is the best in the world and
they want to know how can they do it too
you